particularly in the third movie you see
a lot of personal growth from rg so
it does feel like a proper ending is an
engagement coming soon
oh my god well i don't i i would hope so
very exciting news because you're the
new face of neutrogena
yeah like i grew up watching neutrogena
commercials
and they're so iconic what what does it
mean to you
it means everything to me just like you
i grew up watching like you know the
commercials with the with the splash
like i've been practicing it when i'm
washing my face at night i'll like
practice the splash because i'm like
they always make it look so good because
when you're actually washing your face
you're kind of like
you don't look like that yeah you know
so so it's been amazing and i think that
i have always loved skincare and i've
always loved makeup
i think that just also you know being an
asian american woman
um when i was growing up i didn't often
see if ever a face that looked like me
in like mainstream household name
brands so now the fact that neutrogena
has wanted to work with me
and wanted to for a asian american face
to be a part of their brand that is just
so iconic and
a staple in so many people's homes i'm
really excited and it's honestly my
one of the biggest honors that i've
gotten you know in my career so when you
think about
your beauty ideals what what comes to
mind what does
beauty mean to you whether it be from
to me like the interior but also that of
course
what does it mean of course i mean i
think just like you said like the
biggest thing
for me first and foremost is what's
happening on the inside and
where my mental health is and how
i think like i choose to try and be
positive and
that helps actually helps shows through
your skin right
because if you like labor and all the
negativity you get stressed and then you
start to break out so i definitely focus
on the inside first
um but to me skin care is
self-care right it's like you there's
nothing i think
like there oftentimes i'll get like kind
of like i'll get emotional or have a
rough day
and just washing your face for me
i instantly feel better like i'm like
i'm doing something to take care of
myself
i did see on your instagram last week
did you celebrate five years with your
boyfriend
i did that's a long time that's a really
long
time congratulations that is huge
what what did you guys do to celebrate
well
it was pretty sad because i was in
vancouver doing reshoots for
tall boys three and anthony wasn't
allowed into canada because
they're being really really strict of
course the borders and everything that's
been going on
so we actually didn't celebrate it
together which was really
sad but what we did do is
every night we would put our like the
ipads
next to our pillows and we'd fall asleep
on facetime
because i have nightmares so like oh i
would wake up like anthony
and he'd be like yes so we did that so
during the whole day we were on facetime
and
um we had like we watched we watched a
movie together but
it wasn't anything spectacular how was
quarantine or how is
quarantine with him now i have honestly
really really loved it because i feel
like i got really really busy
um in the past couple of years and i
realized how much
i sometimes would neglect
our relationship because i was just busy
like i'm like i would go to work
and then i'd come home and i'd be so
exhausted that i would just go to bed
i feel like we've grown a lot and he's
my favorite person in the world and he
makes me laugh
there's no one that i would rather like
just sit sit next to yeah
you know so it's been really good it's
been really good obviously there are
days where i'm like
you stay downstairs but for the most
part it has been just like
it's been amazing is is an engagement
coming soon
five years oh my god well i don't i i
i would hope so but you should ask him
but i also was like
i literally told him the other guys like
listen kid
we've been together for five years we
have a house we have a dog
we have a car okay so together you
better
put a ring on it and i always say i'm
always like i'm a hot commodity
you guys were doing reshoots for to all
the boys three what was it like just to
reunite
with noah and the guy being back
together was really amazing and i talked
with noah all the time he's a really
good friend of mine and i think that
i've always felt really grateful for him
because
we like just what we went through in the
past
three years of these movies has really
changed
the both of our lives and it's a such a
weird
weird life change it's nice to have
someone who went through it with you who
can relate to the same things that
you're going through
so it's really great to see him and was
really great to see the rest of the
well the rest of the cast that was there
um
but it was it was weird because i said i
kind of we i wrapped the third movie
like a year ago in korea so i had
said goodbye and i've made my piece with
the fact that
that might be the last time i'll ever
play lara jean and that was really
hard and emotional for me but i had i
had
made my piece with it so coming back to
it was like
ah
we ended on a really really good note
i'm really excited
for people to see the third movie
because i think the third movie is my
favorite movie adam
out of the does it
feel like a true ending the third movie
it does it does which
is sad but also
the ending you will feel really
you'll be like i think we've watched
lara jean and myself grow up through
these movies
and i'm proud of the way that we end
with her like i'm like
that is i'm hopeful for her future
i see a bright future for her and i know
that she's going to go off and and
and occupy her space and do the things
that she loves and she's
you see a lot of growth particularly in
the third movie you see a lot of
personal growth
margin and i think that obviously our
movies are romantic comedy so
they're a lot about the guys um but i do
believe
that third movie is truly about lara
jean and it's not about oh is she going
to pick a guy
all the love triangles all these things
which are great
but i think we also need to focus on
just like who she is
as a young woman and what is she going
to do for the future because she's going
to college and everything so it does
feel like a proper ending
i i you know i don't know i feel sad
about it but you know
but you feel you feel good about it
though yes i do
you